all right Kevin hey Jackie we're doing
something a little different today guys
today we are drawing character mashup
from the wheel we're gonna spin the
wheel twice and whatever two characters
we get we got a mash them up oh god I'm
scared oh boy
Oh Sonic Sonic Sonic that's a solid
solid character and Mario I just have to
technically take one of these characters
and make like a fan Hedgehog who are you
gonna get who's game I'm gonna get no
face first spirited away all right no
face and yeah writing them right on the
edge I'm gonna make you do Kermit Kermit
no face sounds horrifying oh no Johnny
Bravo I'm doing on a trellis current and
Johnny Bravo oh my god oh and this is
great Johnny Bravo oh yes oh
Shrek laughs Oh Jerry
hey you got a mouse Garfield
okay so let's get started let's do it
[Music]
we want to mash the hell out of these
characters just we're doing did it I
don't think I need to use reference
because like Kermit's like literally
just like you know there's like dude I
kind of do yeah a shrek snowman or over
olaf I think over Olaf it's gonna be a
grotesque one for you you know what it
might be because I'm like afraid because
this is just a cat in a mouse should I
draw Kermit drinking the tea oh yes oh
why did you even ask when it's obviously
a yes you got to do the mean gotta do
the what did you decide to go with shrek
snowman try to make it kind of a vibe I
want to go for
did you like frozen field effort I did
not like Bruce but I also like have a
one and a half year old and it's like me
that I will start to like from say God
be ready for that brezin two is coming
so which do you prefer Sonic or Mario I
think Mario I've played more Mario games
this is going here it's supposed to go
weird it's like strange I don't really
know if what we're doing is moral it's
absolutely not my process is most people
probably know this thing is a little bit
different then I think a lot of what
other people have done I use a lot of
shapes I use a lot of forms I work from
values a lot though I like to work from
values because it gets me they look
faster but it is very hard I'm not gonna
make it sound like I just paint in value
you guys will all be alright like it
takes a lot of work it takes a lot of
effort to get good at it
like I spent years getting good at it
like what what process do you prefer but
I think for this one I mainly am
starting from sketching I'm just like
okay I'm trying to feel the gesture and
I'm trying to feel like how the POE is
gonna be okay this is going to be a very
simple drawing is it yeah cuz no faces
body is just black why do you love Shrek
so much Brent you actually talk about
him a lot I do talk about Shrek a lot
it's just something it's half ironic
half genuine love for this character I
just love the the artistic direction
DreamWorks decided to take with these
characters like they weren't really sure
how to do CGI back in the early 2000s
all these creepily realistic basis
I love come at the Frog do you love
Kermit the Frog dude what do you love
most about Kermit the Frog
he's just so good-natured and you're
gonna say he's so good-looking it's just
a handsome young man he's just the most
handsome frog I know he's just trying
the best it can and everyone around him
is an idiot or a weirdo
don't you watch The Muppets he's the
straight man he's the one who's holding
it together wait did he have a short
sleeve shirt Johnny Bravo what is your
real yes she's like a black mask like
masculine shirt that's super muscle
tight like a clever shirt but I like you
going to the club yeah you definitely
skip leg day though that wasn't right
yeah definitely skip leg day dang it I
wish I did better feel self-conscious
again no don't let it don't let the IRD
not you know try my best until zero
seconds Jason you gotta level with me
here you were gonna be running some
childhoods with this one oh yes it's not
even a question I'm gonna try to bring
in some of that DreamWorks detail
because the difference between
DreamWorks and Disney is a priest start
to divide between their approaches to
character design I think the key here is
to just lean into what an abomination
this is the concept of these mashups is
yeah you know like get a Cronenberg
monster out of this thing like oh my god
that's like my dream this is weird
I don't like this get weird with it
Jackie I don't know what to do with his
other hand
[Music]
what are you doing trying to modeling
you want me to model it so you can see
know what I don't need your pity no oh
it's me Sonic I went to AI we had a
teacher who once like told a student
just like look better in two phases like
you'll never make it in this industry
really quit no no I'm not like even
sugarcoating like I'm telling you he
just straight up daughter like don't
chase your dreams quit life and get out
of my room and whoa the reality is like
the industry is not like that you know
people don't like talk to you that way
they they will hire you if they feel
like you're qualified and if you're not
you just got to you've got to work
towards that it's really that simple
stay positive guys keep keep trying yeah
well every day how are you doing we're
surest I feel like it's coming together
it's the creepier the better you know
yeah I went to ambitious but I really
like it it's okay I'm gonna go with it
well this is weird
this is a very strange thing I'm drawing
is it yep so it just looks like Kermit
wearing a black robe sipping tea there
is a meme like that isn't there like
Kermit like talking to himself with the
select a black robe oh yeah that's what
you're doing I don't even think about
that
oh do a double a triple mash up the
triple measurement memes and spirited
away character why not
it's not like we're running out of time
at all okay you know you're right oh but
can you do it I'm gonna try okay come on
hurry all right five minutes Wow get on
it some color
moment of truth Jason green snow or just
gross gross Brown snow I want green snow
greens now all right we're doing it oh
yeah he wants you out of his swamp
because he is the swamp
I am the swamp my Shrek he's a tragic
character you know he's not long for
this world
what does um what do you say like don't
do this guy knows Buzz Lightyear right
like reach for the sky right reach for
the sky wait and mid that woody yeah I
love Toy Story
so much wasn't that great though in that
movie where woody like turns his head
you know like 360 like in that moment
where you're like Sables gonna set them
on fire I love that moment I remember
watching that as a kid and you're like
Joe yes
30 seconds Jackie 30 seconds I believe
in you all right home stretch fast like
sonic excuse me I need to focus and you
you're not helping at all
all right Olaf Olaf Shrek there you go
all right I'm as done is Oliver be for
now all right okay
thinkin I'm good with this yeah how'd
you think you did right well I think I
really captured the spirit of what it
means to mash up two characters into an
ugly abomination it just looks like I
neither know what Sonic or Mario was
like filling in about mine but I I I
think I could have pushed it more mine
looks like I took a Kermit and we
painted him and put him in a giant black
sock huh Wow oh my god this is in credit
or childhood than I did I don't know if
that's true
looks like Kermit died he became the new
Grim Reaper and this is him after a
lovely day of taking people's souls he's
like maybe going to heaven you may be
going to hell that's not my concern
that's what this is it's very spooky
this is actually what I should have done
no or what your narrative is spot-on
like it has so much good character yeah
I think yours is too much it looks like
you've eaten multiple very notable
cherries in there what's up if I had
more time they'd be vomit Jason you're
the childhood Flair hey have yours is
really imaginative is it you know what
yours is a great mashup so here's the
thing don't be so hard on yourself huh
this matchup is incredible I think like
I think yours was very successful okay
yeah I appreciate I think yours is very
successful mashing up characters is on
the spot is very hard yeah you gotta
think of a lot of things and you got a
design it very quickly mashups is a
genuine strategy for design yeah like I
think like people don't realize it a lot
of like your favorite TV shows movies
video games are a mash-up of some sort I
agree I think like mashing up stuff is
also a great way to get out of your
bubble so
I think it's like a great thing for
people to try get out of here Kevin I
don't want to see you anymore
see you tomorrow Oh God
[Music]